hey guys for this tutorial I'm going to
show you how to speed up the Mozilla
Firefox skin in a browser
um I've been slowly moving to Missoula
Firefox for the past few days now I've
been using Safari primarily but this
video is going to be on how to speed up
this is all Firefox so go ahead and open
it up
um if you find that Firefox this is for
this works for version Firefox 3.0.5 uh
so if you have it this will work for you
if you find Firefox slowing down when
opening larger web pages or
um just being slow in general then these
tips will definitely help you so first
of all type in about
type in about colon config
in the start bar where you would
normally type your url hit enter
and we're going to get a whole list of
things that we can tweak Firefox here
now if this is the first time you've
done it it's going to tell you this may
void your warranty just click ok
and what we're going to until first
thing we're gonna end sorry about the
blinking is
pipe lining
and it will sort them out as we're
typing here when we're done typing
pipelining we'll have a number of
uh things that pertain to pipelining
here the first one is called
network.http.pipelining
this we're going to double click
to set the value to true so don't click
it and it'll say it's been user set to
true
the next one to change is
network.http dot pipelining dot Max
requests so if you're if you're loading
a larger website you're going to want
um more connections down in different
parts of the website at the same time so
double click this
and insert a value greater than 50. I'm
using 150 right now I'm going to go
ahead and make that 200 and hit enter
now it's the user set as 200. last but
not least we're going to network HTTP
proxy pipelining pipelining right now
the default is set to false double click
and make that true so now you have these
three values user set to true
that is the first thing you've done so
you've done these three
next we're going to do Max dot
persistent
so go ahead back up to the start the top
again and type in
Max dot persistent
our Dash persistent and we get two
values
Max can persistent connections per proxy
and per server
you're going to
um user set the integer for Server so
double click it and um I've I've been
using 50 right now I'm going to go ahead
and make mine 80. at a certain point the
the value becomes worthless you can't
set it to a trillion and expect it to be
that much higher than setting it to 80
or 50. so I'm going to set mine to 80.
and that is all that is what I do to
make my Firefox faster and if you want
you can exit out of it and restart
um your internet browser and obvious
connections and all these changes will
have taken place now if I open this I
like YouTube it opens it's done
um let's say I open I don't know Myspace
foreign
.com
it opens pretty quickly already
log right in
done
so um this is how you make uh Fox a
faster web browser overall now I will
show you something that will make
Firefox faster but does not work for my
version of Firefox like I showed you 3.0
um this is called faster Fox so I'm
going to go to my uh I mean to go to my
web browser search and I'm going to type
into Google
um
first of all Firefox add-ons
and that's a crash
hopefully that's not permanent so I'll
restart my session
and open up Firefox again
Firefox add-ons
Firefox does just do that once in a
while
um so we'll go to Missoula Firefox
add-ons
and type into yours go ahead and type in
Faster Fox
and this the first one
uh it'll tell you this is a performance
Network tweak for Firefox 1.5 up to
3.0.3
um this will not work with 3.0.5 which
is the newest version which is why this
will be grayed out this will be grayed
out
and that's a theme so faster Fox won't
work
um
so if you do have an older version of
Firefox I would say you should probably
upgrade
um but if you want the leanest version
of Firefox that uses the least amount of
ram then go ahead and
go ahead and download uh the older
version of Firefox and faster Fox will
give you that performance increase
so I hope this helps you increase the
speed of your internet browser and I
should be doing another version of the
video on Safari
and on Internet Explorer so thanks for
watching peace